11 year old Francois matabishi and his
three brothers are building a shelter on
a hill in the village of yamukubi his
parents and other siblings are among
those still missing after the landslide
they sleep in the colds their new home
is leaking and they have no food
we don't have anyone to help us we only
have the clothes we're wearing I don't
know what to do we miss our parents but
they're gone
a short distance away birage cadogo
another Survivor is trying to keep his
wife safe and dry their children are
missing I looked for my children but I
couldn't find them we even searched like
kivo they must be buried underneath the
mud
all these families have similar Stories
the landslide killed hundreds of people
relatives friends and neighbors this is
very much a community mourning people
here are trying to do whatever they can
to rebuild but this area is not safe
they say it's been raining heavily every
day Aid has started trickling in but the
number of people who need help far
exceeds the supplies
government officials say the priority is
moving people to safety we have formed a
committee to gauge when we can declare
the end of the search and Recovery
operation what is important is to
protect those who've been affected and
to make sure we have measures in place
to avoid another tragedy
Francois and his brothers tell us
they're trying to stay strong stay alive
and survive Catherine yamukubi South
kivu Democratic Republic of Congo
Pakistan's government has